And the answer unfortunately is no, we can't solve this. Remember that when we
used the square root sign without any sign explicitly indicated outside of it.
This gives us the positive square root of whatever quantity is inside. Because
we know then for sure this quantity on the left is positive, there is no way
that it can equal a negative number. Which is what's on the right side. So even
thought we now know how to solve a ton of different looking equations, probably
a lot of which it didn't seem at first like we did know how to solve, there are
some that are just not mathematically possible. That has nothing to do with our
math expertise, though. And you've done a really, really awesome job, on this
lesson and on the ones before.